starting banjos back with us once again
guys because we are live here on the
corridor cast to the two chords that
chick knows that's all you need you need
that's more than I know with Nikko once
again hi I'm Nico Christian once again
we are and of course the one and the
only mr. Ren Waichman once again once
again
is everybody doing today good nice yeah
oh my windows open yeah I got my door
open right now there's a fly that just
flew in here mmhmm yeah that's been my
issue with the he is the flies have come
back yeah into my house the air
conditionings out in three so I was
living it up
classic style do you got to get this
Waldo back there yeah I know but it's a
little tough with the quarantine yeah
I'm tell him it's urgent man I need you
listen I I know you're probably doing
quarantine stuff but listen come into my
home home yeah so Wow
so what you guys working on today what
does that mean gone
guess people have to watch the crew
Channel to find out what that means it
was just it's okay Ren you can reveal it
on this channel because only the truest
of the croutons come here yeah we're
basically doing a video kind of trying
to make an impossible Domino's line of
you know you see like those big things
of Domino's they're really cool but what
if they did things that
real Domino's can't do like go up walls
or be the size of buildings so nice yeah
another one of wrens craziest Domino
effects well that's the thing we're
doing a crew video kind of testing the
concept for it's in partnership with
Nvidia but the idea is that we're kind
of exploring the possibility of doing
like an even bigger version of it's for
the actual corridor digital channel in
that daylight like a mad scientist type
video yeah that'll be a fun one I hope
you I hope it works because I think that
video would be fun to shoot and
obviously it perform really well and
it'd be a good new I guess novel
experimentation with the effects so the
starting banjo back up because we've
we've begun yeah well I guess do you
wanna do you want to talk about the this
other big news Niko yeah I mean on
behalf of Jake I'm announcing that Jake
is moving to Texas I know you spooked
everybody last week saying Niko is
leaving the studio
that'll be guys make are you quitting
corridor digital work no so here's the
thing
no not not going anywhere at least not
in not in terms of my my presence as a
creator within corridor digital I am
going to more physically and that is to
San Antonio so there's a few reasons for
that but I am gonna be back regularly to
be in studio to work out of the studio
and yeah my new life is gonna Crowley
consists of spending two or so weeks in
Texas and the
spending a week or so in LA and doing
that pretty much to infinity so yeah
obviously we've been doing more stuff
over there with black raffle coffee
we've sort of fostered a relationship
with those guys they have access to so
many filmmaking resources that it's kind
of its kind of ridiculous just because
of you know who what they've done I
guess in life's prior and then as as
black rifle has kind of expanded it's
just presented this opportunity with us
where they're like hey we've been
watching you guys you know when they
first came to us they like Jared Jared
and and rich and Matt we're like well
obviously we knew rich but we didn't
know Jared and Matt at the time and it
turns out those guys had been watching
our videos for like ten years
yeah there's like huge fans yeah
and so you know they'd seen everything
that we'd done and you know they just I
guess what they wanted was a little bit
of our expertise so that they can learn
from us and we can learn from them and
there's just a lot of different avenues
that we can go with them so I'm gonna go
foster that and also you know it came
down to having now a third kid on the
way which we announced this last time
right oh wait oh it's breached more news
because we changed the whole website
that's right yeah you're just a
gender-reveal baby Jake your sense of
like you know dramatic pacing is a
little off right now guys I'm sorry it's
been it's been a long week it's been a
long quarantine so you know chicks with
Texas hands come on kid okay but yeah
vodcast yeah so again sounds crazy but
it's you know something that we've been
thinking about and working towards here
for well quite some time actually and
I'm just glad that um well that was you
know part of that decision was like hey
should we move the studio should we
should we do this like as a company or
how should we try to how should we try
to foster this and arrange this and I
feel like after all these years of being
patient and visiting places and getting
input from the team and getting getting
everyone sort of two cents and and
seeing how things evolved and being
flexible to do it I feel like finally
you know with with Nikko coming out of
studio three us going up there as well
and then me doing this move I feel like
it's kind of the best of all worlds and
it wouldn't have happened had we not
been patient and had we not been like I
guess just you know it's it's such a
monumental decision to be like okay I'm
gonna move to a different place or we're
gonna move our company to a different
place I don't think people realize just
how like in depth in how long our search
were moving actually was it was a year
and a half we looked at three different
states yeah it was an extensive search
everyone at the company did a lot of
soul searching yep yeah and I'm glad I'm
glad that had happened and I'm glad I
feel like you know although there were
certain like you know there were certain
people that were more willing to move or
more interested in moving than others at
the same time it required of everybody
to do that soul searching and that I
feel like makes us better off going
forward because you've gone through that
process now it's not like oh why do why
do I work here or why am I here at this
job or why am I here in LA or why am i
doing X Y & Z you know you you're now
taken the mental energy to spend time on
that because you've you know
may-maybe were forced to or maybe you
were gonna do it anyways but regardless
it's been done and so that I guess just
opens us up to more good things going
forward because now it's like okay
everybody that's here is here to be
doing this mm-hmm and and you know the
hardest thing I feel like as uh as as
one of the partners Nikko you know speak
to this too but like it's just making
sure that everybody can continue to do
that I feel like that's that's the
biggest challenge
just making sure that like because you
know like raden for example I mean when
we started working with you you you know
so many years ago I was like 12 it was
2012 or so
alright years ago yeah and and what
you've done with us and and what you've
done on your own and and like with your
with your most recent quote-unquote ran
videos I mean it's just it's been a
journey in and of itself watching you
evolve as a creator and you involved you
have you've evolved the ton and you know
the interesting thing is I don't I don't
see this physical move as anything but
part of that process for me and so you
know you can come off as a bit of a
shock to be like wait you're you're
doing what but you know you got to
remember also 2009 I put everything I
own into a car and drove out here to
begin with so it's about that but me to
be like yeah I'm just gonna keep
evolving this way did you find a house I
did yeah yep I found one and yeah twelve
yeah twelve bedroom Assaf mansion Sofia
mansion is a loose term yeah no but it's
it is nice for a large family because
you can just get so much more out there
in terms of space and stuff and you know
with it with now a third baby on the way
Plus Wendy's mom lives with us too so I
got
full house man and room for everybody
now which is nice because certainly out
this house that I'm in now is great but
it's a great house you had a ton of room
here I used to have an office man
I used to have my you set up in your
living room when I was like don't you
have a whole office in the back room and
I was just kinda like well maybe he just
wants to be out in the open but I was
happy what happened back there so no not
anymore now my mother-in-law lives back
there dude she was and now upstairs is
Elijah's room now they got a Liza and
Jada doesn't have his own he's in your
room yeah so he's moving into his own
room when we moved so you know just as
as the family grew we just needed more
space that's all that's all there's to
it yeah I mean I think the big thing
with like all the move move planning
that we do that corridor for you know
for the past two years not three like if
you think back to when it started it's
you know it starts off you're
20-something kids in LA you're like well
I like doing this do you like doing this
yeah I like doing this cool let's start
doing it together
yeah okay we need some more help do you
like doing this I like doing this cool
uh you want me your computer in and
we'll work together on something cool
and then like nothing start growing and
we if you're committed to it and you
want to make it happen it happens like
anything in life it's not an instant
overnight success it's a long long build
the winds up happening is that you turn
around you look back instantly five
years I've passed eight years have
passed like whoa what started as just
say hey I like doing this you like doing
this to put our computers in the same
room and keep doing it is now turned
into hey I've been here for longer than
I was at college I've been here for
almost as long as the I was in my
hometown when I grew up and it's like
yeah amazing
coming up on it I've almost lived in the
studio here on Hunter Street longer than
I lived in my house and still auteurs I
grew up in yeah so I'm only like three
years away from that that time but
you know there was a point here where
unless somebody takes a lot of time to
do soul searching all the time which I
don't know if that's really our group
outside of Clint you know it's there
wasn't really a moment here I think
where people had stopped me like well
how long do I want to work here what is
my goal with this like is this something
I want to do and what would that what
would that look like what's the shape of
that be so the move was also a chance
for us to do that and to be like you
know what how do we want to make films
how do we want to work together here
like do you want to get out of LA and be
doing a lot more personal kind of
projects where where it's just us just
the group doing our own thing you know
life is easy life is cheap and you know
we're just going out in the woods and
shooting videos do we want to try to
make a you know film industry blow up to
another city that doesn't have it do we
want to try you want to stay in LA and
keep you know playing this game here and
then you know in the entertainment
capital of the world which you know
entails a different pace of life as well
and you know I think you know in that
process like I came to a lot of
conclusions Jake came to a lot of
conclusions Sam came to a lot of
conclusions but not just us you know
it's it's rain it's Christian it's all
the guys at core door had a chance to
really think about this and maybe it
wasn't as big of a deal for like the
guys that joined us like last year like
Dean and Matt but for the rest of us you
know it's time for us to really consider
like hey where are we and where are we
at in life and this thing that none of
us quite thought would really turn into
a career has turned into a long-term
career what does that mean and what does
that entail and what what do we need
from that right yeah guys and it's been
it well that's like you said like it's
it's not like we sound like we not like
we showed up one day and we're like hey
do you want to do this for a career you
wanna see if we can grow this into a
functioning business know shooting
videos you know yeah things about next
week's video that's as far as yeah yeah
exactly I mean I do remember the moment
that I quit my law office what was that
like we did you do it like a double
table yeah dudes working out
you know he stole like a bunch of snacks
we still got a baby I mean no because we
never print anything what do we print I
think actually no Christian you did buy
a baller buy and we're at the point
where we're buying our paper okay look
at that paper that paper lasted us like
a good six years Wow
I mean yeah we didn't even get a new
functioning printer until I got back in
order
yeah there wasn't even really a working
printer what I mean kind of my first
joint yeah I was like janky rank yeah
Jake which ad had you had like this
old-ass laptop and this printer that you
carry it around and you had you had it
in like the motor home for sink and
you're printing off like contracts and
invoices and stuff like that like you're
so stressed that you're late for law
school like that was such a rough time I
mean looking back on it I probably
shouldn't have been that stress but it
was my first time with all of that stuff
and like you know salmon Negro and I
were shooting videos and then all the
sudden big frame was like hey we got all
this money for a webseries you want to
do a webseries and we're like we had
never produced anything like that of
that scale or anything just to give you
a sense of that it was 90 minutes we had
a script kind of we did not start gonna
do half a script half a script we didn't
start producing it until two weeks
before the first shoot date and we just
assumed that that would be enough time
because we were we were working on our
two-week schedule for YouTube releases
and then just the next one came up it
was like yeah that's basically how that
one fit in there and then there was this
lion producer that came from
like traditional TV and he just could
not wrap his head around like how we did
things and it was very stressful working
with him because he was now he's getting
we had no trust obviously because I was
we were these kids basically and and and
they were like okay here's a bunch of
money guys
don't mess it up but also do it our way
because we've done it this way and we
didn't mess it up so you need to do it
this way because the probability of you
messing it up but the problem was they
didn't have enough money for us to do it
that way and what we were trying to do
creatively like you couldn't do it that
way with that money so I was constantly
at odds with this guy and it was like
not only was I at odds with that guy I
was producing this 90 minute thing for
the first time and I was still a
part-time in law school so I would have
to leave set every day at 5:00 to go to
class and then I'd have to go to class
from like 5:30 6:00 to 9:00 and then
like prepare for the next day and then
literally like 6 a.m. 7 a.m. the next
morning like be back on set and it was
so yeah and I was the whole time I was
carrying around this thing I got that
off ebay from some woman in like win
like Winchester or like Seal Beach or
something I bought a couch and I was
buying this couch as she was moving out
and I didn't have a printer and she and
I was like hey are you selling that
printer and I bought it from her the
thing was the thing I liked about that
printers that had no firmware you could
plug it into any that's why I loved it
around with me I'll get into anything
and it would print wow man you're saying
you're telling me that we could be in
like a golden era of printer technology
if printer manufactures weren't such
dicks about it yes why does it why does
a printer need firmware
doesn't just plug it in recognize device
print I'm curious
Christian and Ren you know we were
talking about the move and this whole
searching and all that kind of stuff
where did you guys end up with your soul
search that's a broad question welcome
to the corner Capps where broad
questions get sometimes broad answers
sometimes yeah I mean the broad question
there yeah obviously when it was
presented to us it's like yeah basically
it's that moment it's like oh yeah okay
you gotta start thinking about this this
is like a real decision and that kind of
starts the whole soul-searching process
you know it's like not just like oh yeah
I'm like my you know where do I want to
move it's like you know you start
thinking oh yeah like you said the
company and what you want to do in the
future and you got to think about all
the different connections so so
initially I was it was a little I mean
to be honest I didn't expect it I don't
know if there was whispers behind prior
to that or anything but the meeting when
you sim or Jake Sam and Nico called me
into the room and told us about it that
was like the first time I heard about it
I was like oh shoot like this is I had
no idea this was coming so it was like
almost like initially it was like a
little bit like I'm a freak out because
it's like oh my god what's going to
happen mm-hmm then yeah like um I kind
of just trusted you guys in the process
for a while and I was open to it I was
you know receptive receptive to it right
when I heard from it so you know I kind
of from there was excited about just
seeing the places first and kind of
hearing more about the plan you know and
again read said that was like a
year-and-a-half process and by the end
of it me and Chelsea were pretty much
ready to go like you know obviously and
we didn't get into the details of
anything but we came to the conclusion
that like and there's a lot of factors
for me too so I'm from LA from Southern
California
my parents are two hours south of here
so that was a big kind of hurl or a
hurdle I initially had to get over yeah
by the end of it we were we were you
know we saw as a positive opportunity to
even if we were just gonna take the you
know go there
for the term amount or whatever when we
talked about you know yeah your thing
and beer then and then kind of
renegotiate from there we kind of saw at
least for the the minimum term of three
years you know it's just something that
we were willing to do
I wouldn't say like we were all for it
and I was you know running around trying
to convince everybody to move because it
was something I really wanted to do but
it was like something that we saw as
something that we can take as a positive
grow for a little bit and you know it
was always kind of like we can come back
if we need to so yeah by the end of it
we were kind of excited about it kind of
saw the potential opportunities just
save and figure out different things
like that and grow personally in a new
city you know and obviously with the
company because I was excited to see
where a corridor was going and you know
especially for right now I'm not
planning to look anywhere else so so ya
know it was something I was willing to
do um but at the same time I would say
there was a bit of almost like a relief
when when it ended up not happening you
know
mmm just for the fact of the you know
the things I told I mean I don't have to
snap look into you know look looking at
a new place to live and the moving
expenses and leaving my family and you
know we've even talked about like when
we have kids it's like we want to be
near family too so it's like how far out
is that and is that gonna happen when
we're out of state away from the
families and stuff cuz her family's here
too so yeah I mean in a way there is a
there was a yeah kind of a weight off
the shoulders at the end but you know we
were willing to go the company and kind
of take the positives for what they were
and grow from there and kind of you know
commit to it for that for that time
being and see where it went from there
you know I don't know if if we if the
company decide to move if Texas would
have been a long-term or forever place
for me ultimately but you know we were
gonna take it in the short chunks from
there at time but uh yeah in a way it
now that it's not officially happening
then you know I'm happy to stay here in
my home state because this is home to me
so you know I'm not leaving home so
there's there's you know it's not like
there's a huge something here from
somewhere else yeah yeah yeah yeah no it
was definitely a process the thought
process and the discussions you know
I've talked a lot with my parents to you
and I know they're free
and family and there's a you know it
became a whole you know top of your
discussion in it to every with everybody
that was close to me in my life so you
know me mom like my Ella goober friends
there was a there was definitely time
when it was like oh yeah like thing that
sucks you guys are gonna move out of
state because they were they were ready
for us to go know and that's just you
know that's just part of the
relationship and stuff but yeah again I
think we would have been happy if we did
move and we would have managed and kind
of figured out how to you know and
continue our personal growth and
anywhere we go so yeah I know there's an
interesting prospect again that's kind
of where Ian landed but there's a yeah
now that we're not going I guess there's
nothing really the action on to be able
to move on you know I mean has it has
the fact or not going as a change how
you're approaching Los Angeles
absolutely oh there's that too
there was so yeah actually that's a
whole logistically I didn't even think
about so when we got back from that it
was a second I guess the November Texas
trip with GRCC we were already in the
process of moving and it was super so
much it to the point to where like I got
back from Texas
Chelsea booked the place and we were
moving like the end of that week but she
did a made amazing job like making sure
we had a nine month lease because we
were like okay well we might be moving
to Texas at the time that you guys had
told us we were gonna go and that's
about nine months from now so she did
all the work to like fit our least that
way and the Landlord ended up being cool
with it and we told him like hey there's
a big chance that the company's moving
and we need to go here but I will say
it's like we're now living in the best
department I've probably lived in other
than the house that others with Jake you
know this is like probably the best
place I've lived in in LA and we first
moved in we didn't we were like well you
know it's five months let's not really
build it out listen we're not gonna
really invest too much into like you
know really settling in here if if the
plan is to move in nine months but ya
know never since the call was made to
not go then yeah we're we're doing those
same things but here kind of like let's
start settling in here getting things
you want but also like kind of like the
last podcast I've been now looking in
just investments and saving my money in
a different way and and just making mile
a lifestyle work for you know my future
personal
so you know and whether it's the
investments are saving money or settling
into the house year we just started our
herb garden so we're gonna start growing
the long term things like that so yeah
no it definitely adjusted the approach
of just like yeah how we want to kind of
keep planning for our future here now
that it's here we kind of know the place
where it might it's gonna happen for the
foreseeable future so now I'm just kind
of taking the steps to start moving
toward yeah and that uncertainty can be
difficult in and of itself you know
that's almost it's almost more difficult
than that actually
I guess the prospect of like leaving
somewhere and going to another is almost
the uncertainty of what it brings or
what it doesn't bring totally I would
say the certainty of us are also not
knowing you know that would not
necessarily the certainty of when you
get to the new place but it was almost
like also kind of that period of just
kind of like well one are we moving and
- have you made a decision where that
whole kind of like period of uncertainty
was definitely yeah like the hardest
part for us to kind of really grasp
because then yeah it's like I got some
people on my mind or my parents are like
you know you know you guys can make the
decision when it comes there whereas
like I have another group of friends
it's like already seeing us has moved
out of the state and they're like I
don't really know exactly so that's
where it's like yeah you either of you
guys could be right I'm not really sure
we're just figuring it out but you know
I definitely kept my loved ones in the
loop the whole process and it helped for
sure
what are you Ren uh did oh so for me it
was like okay so I come from a
background of having moved a lot growing
up I've lived in Louisiana Texas
Oklahoma I did Middle School in Norway
High School in Texas in Vietnam and in
college in Portland in a little bit in
Seattle but just because Ren hua asked
his parents to move to those places and
then they took and my dad's a geologist
so he worked a lot on like like in the
oil industry and whatnot so it allowed
us to move over
a lot which is really really cool um I
had a really blessed childhood in that
regard so I was coming from the
perspective of I don't mind moving like
when I moved to LA I literally just put
everything in my car and just drove down
here and then figured out what to do
wait where am I gonna stay
so the first like night I stayed in the
Whole Foods parking lot in Santa Monica
and I went to Santa Monica because that
was the only place in LA that I knew
about yeah I ended up that first night
and then uh shortly after that I ended
up with fullscreen I'm going on this
random engine but basically fullscreen
was like a company of ten employees at
the time and they let me sleep on their
company couch but two straight weeks
before I found an apartment pretty
quickly but it's like a process like I
was just I was just joking this morning
about how all the all the people that
aren't from LA like why there's so many
homeless people in Santa Monica because
what am i what am i made-up totally
irrelevant theories was that it's
because people that come here that don't
know anything about the city all they've
heard of a Santa Monica like a figure
they just go to Santa Monica and they're
like what do I do now and you either
like integrate into society or like you
never leave and you end up there what
United there's some truth to that but
only in that joking manner yeah the
second night I did stay in a hotel I
wasn't gonna stay in first thing I did
after getting down here and staying that
first night was uh getting a public
storage unit just putting all my stuff
in there yeah so then I was at least
able to be like mobile and flexible yes
so I guess that's just kind of backstory
on like me not minding moving that much
I'd since lived in two more places I've
lived in three different places here in
LA
currently in Pasadena and I love passing
I fell in love with it and so started
this whole moving process I was like I
don't know I kind of like it here but
I'm open to moving to somewhere that's
cheaper but granted that that was only
one half the equation because my wife
Jenna is
second she ended up getting a really
really nice job in the combat the
complication with that is that she
couldn't she wouldn't be able to just
laterally move to that same position in
some other Hospital yeah work her way
back up to that probably starting it
nice shift all over again she did that
for years then went to day shift for a
year and now bazan she's running the
entire floor she's like the floor
manager floor box yeah yeah the charge
nurse patient flow coordinator if you
will so it was we had looked at a few
different places I guess we went to
Minnesota and we looked at like
Minneapolis and like a few different
location then went to Austin looked at
some places around there in San Antonio
then we went to Portland Oregon in
Seattle Washington and after all of that
after like a couple months or like maybe
just one or two months after that on our
morning Monday morning meaning you guys
decided Portland is it yeah I moved to
Portland and it was at that precise
moment that I realized okay so before
that though up until this time I've
considered myself from Portland that's
where I went to college even though it
was only for four years that was the
longest time I've ever lived in any one
location yeah so I yeah yeah nice like
that very like this real connection to
Portland I loved it and I'd love to move
back so when you guys decided we're
moving to Portland and I realized I
didn't want to move that was a big
moment for me internally I was like huh
that's odd
I don't want to go to the one place on
earth I'd like to move to I I realize
I'm not in a place in my life where I
want to leave LA you know I don't have
kids I don't have other sort of like
wife responsibilities that kind of are
you know meaning a cheaper cost of
living and whatnot I really like Los
Angeles though and that was what I
really kind of started realizing Los
Angeles is a beautiful city there's so
much to it in terms of like just being
able to go out one wheeling up to the
top of a mountain that is ten minutes
away
like literally I could drive for ten
minutes and then start one wheeling up
to the top of the mountain and have like
the most epic you of all time now that
you have your xrj we've got to do this
right very soon yeah and
like everything there's so many like
groups that are here so many different
types of cuisine and people that are
here in LA is there such a big melting
pot that you don't get in other cities
like Portland or not I wouldn't be
opposed to moving a little outside of LA
you know especially cuz I have a car
that drives itself it's like that
literally changes everything in my
mentality about like your many things
are it's it's kind of bizarre how much
that literally just changes yeah you
know if I if I move like 30 40 minutes
east of here I'm pretty much outside of
LA and downtown LA is an hour away yeah
but if that means I can actually get a
really nice place or not too expensive
and that's that's something I'll
probably in the future think about I'm
not in a position to think about it
owning a house yet I have too many other
your responsible financial decisions I'm
working on that at myself I came down to
like alright um you guys are wanting to
move and I'm kind of wanting to not move
so I had to start thinking about what am
I gonna do and I've since learned that
Jenna was not going to move she looks at
me she's like I wasn't gonna grand I
think there's a huge asterisk there she
probably would there's a lot of unknowns
in that if it went the other way yeah
yeah I guess that's what I'm that's what
I'm saying like I feel like we get we
get the best of both worlds with all
this because you know we'll get some of
the we get some of the expansion like
and and some of the connections that
that we been that we've been getting out
there well at the same time you know it
doesn't it doesn't put anyone in a bad
way where you know you're you're like
your wife's not moving or you you you
know you you have a
I don't know it's so many different
issues for an all possibilities arise
from that yeah well then yeah now it
does it does affect us like in the way
of you know our costs and things like
that but you know I kept finding myself
thinking can we just put this off one
more year I mean there's there's the
argument that like you're never gonna be
ready for whatever it is that you need
to be ready for my agenda but at the
same time I was like just one more I
wanna have like another year in LA yeah
I don't like that year when my nose like
that combined with me realizing I didn't
want to move to Portland at least not
yet I mean you realize that I didn't
want to leave LA I think LA still has
too many things to offer for me both
socially and professionally and that was
one of the big reasons why you guys
decided to not move the company is
because when we started this search
corridor was a very different company
than it turned into at the beginning of
this year by the time yeah I mean we've
yeah we've been at least like in passing
discussing the idea for god I don't even
know like since there was just like me
Uttam Nikko and Carmichael yeah at least
in passing and then Christian came on
and then Nick came on and then you know
it's just doubled more than doubled in
size and so now all of a sudden it's not
just about you anymore you know it's not
just about any one individual anymore
it's there's a whole team of people to
consider and everyone's got different
life's and everyone's got different asks
and different things that they are that
are important to them and all that stuff
is really at the heart of why you try to
work to find your your favorite course
of working in the first place you know
is so that you can have all of these you
can have the things that are more
important than that to you
and so just balancing that sometimes is
it says is a
that's what you can't just like wake up
and be like oh we're gonna do this
alright but it would be hasty and
probably unwise yeah so we got to that
fateful point you know after I redid all
the soul-searching where you know we
were looking at basically had gone
through the fall here of 2019 and like
every other week either some big-name
person was coming into the studio or
working with some big-name person like
you know he worked with Will Smith for
that quick deep fake joke for Gemini man
you know we had the VFX supervisor come
in from venture and game yeah we had a
Snoop Dog you know we did a project with
him Rogen yes right but you know so and
I'm leaving so many different names
office lists you know we had a bunch of
caen stunt men come in wheeler I was
that one guy's name Iran came in for you
know study on react yep Eric and then
like other companies are coming in while
weird like for you the other side like
of the non VFX react and stuntman react
we had you know we did the thing with
unreal unlike a little mini version of
the use of the Mandalorian yeah anyways
the the list goes on and as well those
things were it's like that wasn't
happening in 2018 and that wasn't
happening in 2017 like in 2018 and 2017
it was just a couple of friends making
videos and that's all it was his insular
we weren't really a big deal on YouTube
anymore you know we're getting like
200,000 views per video crazy part about
this real quick tour was a huge deal
about like 8 to 10 years ago yeah deal
man we used to be the 80th most
subscribed channel on the
and now most of our fans these days
don't even know we existed before this
year yeah yeah but you know thinking
about it and thinking about it and
thinking about it you know based on what
had happened and like how much had had
grown and like you know just where we
were as a company at least I came to the
conclusion that I didn't think the move
was the right move anymore and then came
the really challenging part of having to
face Jake and tell him that Jake all
this work that you put in for the past
two years and all these expectations
that we have communicated at the last
second I have to say I'm sorry but I
don't want to do it anymore so you know
I think is a testament to like how I
think how good partners you know both
Jake and Sam are is that like you know
we have this discussion and like you
know obviously emotions are involved but
like we've been around long enough now
that we can we can digest our emotions
we can talk about things and like you
know challenges don't come without
emotions challenges are very rarely just
like yeah whatever
hey you're like what are your rocket
crews died should I keep going yeah
whatever yeah but you know we talked
about it and we talked about it and you
know work through a way to to our
conclusion of the yards you know it's
staying in LA is the right move but Jake
as he told us he was gonna get out of
Los Angeles it was time for him to leave
and you know we understand that there's
there's a large component of this which
is your personal life in your personal
life in your work life especially when
it's art are very tied together yeah um
and you know it's important that we
figured out a way to support that and
encourage things and I think this
quarantine is shown that just how much
work we can do without having to be in
the same room and don't get me wrong
it's very like every was like well why
doesn't everybody just work from home
it's like well there's an undeniable
value to all being in the
let's not kid ourselves like maybe if
you're really antisocial and you don't
really talk to people at your job it
might feel like you do all your work
from home that's cool
but especially at corridor there's a lot
of value to being in the same space but
that's it there's entire industries that
can't be done yes yes but but there's
also a lot of work we can do when we're
not in the same space and you know so it
kind of brought us to this point where
it's like all right well let's let's
move on to this you know it's Plan B
which is you continue pursuing the
things that you want to pursue in life
and we'll figure out how to work
remotely but also you know Austin Texas
isn't that far away from Los Angeles and
you know the the the thing that was up
in the air is whether or not we would
have studio three by the time Jake had
moved when I say we I mean as in
corridor would have studio three because
I live in Studio three which in the
building there's studio 4 which is
corridor in Studio three which is my
place what used to be corridor next week
we're doing a special 10-year idiot yeah
studio yeah we'll do a walk through like
looking at all though old spots for cool
things happen maybe some cool locations
around the studio and a little
retrospective on ten years of corridor
which by the way like maybe this is the
transition point here but I remember
like so we'll probably cover this in the
video but like I remember how it all
started with like Freddie and David
Welch going up to the Olympics in
Vancouver in 2010 and meeting DeStorm
because they were doing a video thing
for Samsung and a CERN was the only like
one of the he's the only guy anybody
knew who was doing YouTube he was
partnered at the time he told Freddie to
get into it Brandon and Freddie had had
a viral video go viral
mainly because at the time the people
that worked at YouTube that curated the
front page of YouTube comm liked one of
their videos and put it there for a
couple of weeks and for something like
that or something video no no this is
the Guitar Hero video no no it's just
it's literally just Freddie
playing guitar here maybe it's like
really old Freddy W the one of him
spinning on the ground
it's called Guitar Hero YYZ is here the
video has 9.2 million views it's just
you know some dude in his apartment yeah
it starts with him on the dirt bike
being like I'm a badass and watch me
play guitar hero and then you know this
kind of nerdy kid goes and plays a
really good job at Guitar Hero and
call today yeah and so a lot of people
saw that and you know Freddy and Brandon
saw some potential but that was like
that was a few years before they started
their YouTube channel I was like a solid
three or four years before they actually
started the channel
I mean her singular video on YouTube
yeah just for fun and you know I got
views and odd stuff but like I remember
sitting outside on the street in the bed
of Kevin clobbers pickup truck and Kevin
clobbers he edited a bunch of stuff like
Nine Inch Nails and Smashing Pumpkins
back in the day it's a really talented
editor he's won awards and he had a
pickup truck there's like purple with
like flames drop like painted on it he's
the only friend that had a pickup truck
so anytime people need to move they had
to borrow his truck but I remember
sitting the bed of the truck with
Brandon and Freddy because we had been
working on dark island the movie that
you know we shop and when Coover at the
time and Freddy was like you know so I'm
gonna be trying to see YouTube thing you
know I learned a lot about it when I was
up in Vancouver for the Olympics and
yeah you know I'm gonna kick that off
cause they're all working on the same
stuff into the same roof and we're like
okay cool and Sam are still doing our
own thing we're doing you know freelance
visual effects and I remember that
conversation we kind of thinking like
you know that'd be cool to try and then
like if we get into it we'll probably do
it for a couple years before you know
ideally it leads to us making a movie or
something like that and man here we are
10 years later is crazy
you've been coming to the same party for
10 years
yeah that little bit of like I guess
it'll leave that us making a movie okay
it did happen but then we just came back
to YouTube afterwards like that that
end-all be-all of like Oh make a movie
and then that's the end like it's like
no you keep making stuff it works though
either yeah it's not let's keep doing it
yeah there's there's there's not there's
always that there's always that phrase
especially with Los Angeles and when
you've made it yeah you made it you made
it like that but the thing is is that
doesn't there is no point at which you
make it and then all the sudden you're
made a club yeah
like I did have a threshold for making
it by the way oh yes it's always a prism
I made it Jake you all know my threshold
was I made it like 20 when do we do the
the collaboration is Epic Meal Time
that's when you know that's what I made
it doing the collab now it's like 2013
yeah
when they collab with us specifically on
the corridor channel no but we did put
unlimited glasses on unlimited glasses
on muscles glasses anyways it was a very
simple threshold right so that's smart
and final which is now like a mini
version of Costco you don't need a
membership there this extra this extra
large pack of bacon bacon is like the
leftovers no they have the bacon ends
but they also got all my bacon strips
but it's like a three pound pack or
maybe it's bigger it's like 30 bucks all
right Bacon's really good I was really
poor like there's a point in time when
making or literally all you eat is rice
and beans out of a giant being cast like
all of us like these am pregnant ready
but rice and tortilla and beans and we
eat that and then be our lunch
dinner like didn't have very much money
cuz we don't working we were working at
dock island so like entirely I may say
things this is coming out of college I
didn't have a lot of savings so anyways
so I remember when a smart file and you
know I'd be getting groceries and I saw
that and I thought to myself very
clearly when I can buy that pack of
bacon I'll have made it I guess I have a
very low threshold for making it anyways
we filmed that that episode in the
course those guys threw a brushless
giant packs of bacon in the cart and I
know I didn't buy it they did but the
same time the fact that there was
multiple packs of that bacon yeah and it
tied into this collab with one of the
biggest YouTube names which made our
channel which meant our channel is
becoming legitimate and like you know
that was the threshold of making it it's
like when that pack of bacon ended up
back at my studio and being used in the
video it's like I knew that we were OK I
knew that we had it we had to figure it
out from that point on that's great dude
though like you kind of need to you kind
of need to set those those mini goals
yeah and my other definition my other
thing I'm making I'll just I'll keep
this one really quick it's very simple
it is my definition of being famous was
having somebody know my name without me
knowing there's like somebody who knew
me and I've never seen them before
happen in the first week of college
videos like oh cool it's like are you
Nico like yeah who are you it's like I'm
Josh oh cool nice to meet you just
waiting yeah yes either Joshua oh I
can't member which one one of those guys
what's that no no yeah Josh son sung in
our band for a little bit mm-hmm yep you
still didn't know his name no I just in
the memory I can't remember who was the
guy that had mentioned oh yeah I saw
your video yeah it's one of those too
but anyways
yep yeah I mean I'd be different for
anybody like making it to one person is
completely different than somebody else
making it making it could be a family in
a house for somebody whereas you know
somebody could be like I want to win an
Oscar yeah it's a personal journey on
that end an Oscar would be nice yeah
that got enough screaming but then you
get that Oscar and it's like Oh can't do
this anymore
still gotta eat your bills and all that
good stuff
yeah plus you've committed your entire
life to to get that off zero for you
away from it now yeah I'm gonna go start
over I guess there are people that have
done that and do that I'm sure I don't
think I don't think I'm one of them yeah
same there's enough variety and the
world of corridor digital to keep oh
yeah it's maybe a new career every year
yeah yeah my most favorite part about
the stuff that we do it's just like
nothing's mundane or it's like obviously
you have tasks that can get like tedious
but this nation yeah but other than that
like nothing's really ever the same
thing every day that we do you know
that's the best part at least
year-to-year it certainly changes well
that's their cabin fever if I work on
the same project for too long like
you'll crank it on the same project for
like more than a month I'm like oh god
I'm like x2 but that was approaching
that point the worship was an amazing
self-driving cars that was that was that
was like three months of working on that
video yeah and I had a lot of issues
along the way working on it was
frustrating
sanehat Sam had a baby so he like he's
doubt for a month well speaking of
speaking of some blockbusters some
corridor blockbusters what are we gonna
do next boys we're gonna do another boss
town yes I was coming is that you got
the boss man over you monsters you know
very close tactical is close we got this
world's biggest Domino sequence coming
up at some point that might that might
be on that into the actual corridor
video for sure soon especially not all
this testing is going into it I think
that would be a good video - yeah or
wacky boys with the cell phone thank you
for her to do this again we'd probably
want to shoot on go program that feel
that feel of just captured right there
in real time so yeah something about
that phone look I know we have to admit
the settings though to make the tracking
easy
I mean GoPro would probably give you
that feel right hey would but there's a
distant benefit of like the nice audio
in the you know I don't know it smells
it into that cameras move differently
you know yeah yeah
well guys that's the journey of that
time we almost moved our entire company
you heard it here first and hey what do
you think of these socks Oh where'd you
see green screen socks oh my god if you
need to key out your feet classy
yeah yeah course of course if you just
need tracking on your foot only make its
hi which make a mocap tile oh man oh
I would wear that yellow design yeah
that's pretty cool
we should make always we go to all these
YouTube events in LA we're gonna be
dressed
I want you milk appetite I didn't
realize how much I wanted one two I said
to you I will I would make a point of
wearing suits to work we should have a
formal I just like Jared and Krishna
Carmichael Carmichael used to do
you've heard it or that just imagine
that boys
right on the right on the knot soon very
soon in fact if you guys are members of
our website you will find out their
first you also get 15% off I don't have
an exact date it will probably be in
June though and it's gonna not just be a
mocap hoody oh it's gonna be so much
more than that
you big drop yeah well we're also gonna
do some of them this month so there's
some probably in two weeks there's gonna
be a bunch of new stuff end of restocks
stuff that's been out of stock for a
long time that people have been asking
for Oh get ready you know speaking of
the website yeah so anybody who's
listening to the podcast this far yeah
or you're in a very very small select
group of people that enjoy the content
that we make so - you listening right
now I wanna speak to joy so we have our
website watch corridor comm eventually
corridor digital calm all right so it's
quarter digital calm and it's right now
it's becoming we have what we have
created rather what Jake and Scott have
created is a website that it's all
things corridor it's all our videos from
our all our channels add free plus
discount on the any merch in the merch
store plus a monthly hangout
Plus this cool new crowdfunding system
where you don't have putting any money
into it but basically just through your
subscription you get corridor boxes I
don't know we have it forever and we
haven't rolled this out yet this
deceptive you're already working on the
designs for it literally right now but
basically with each month you get like a
certain number of points and you get to
pledge those points to a project and
basically what you're saying is I want
you to take my subscription for that
month so well I believe it's what is it
399 a month to a year and it's cheaper
but yeah yeah so I want you to take 3 my
399 of course there's you know some
hosting fees and so like that that come
out of that but whatever is leftover I
want you to put it as a budget into this
project so imagine if Netflix aside just
putting things out hope you'd like it
would ask like what would you like to
fund it through subscriptions back I
want that and then if you and enough
other people did that at the same time
it would get made that's the thing we
wanted to bring to this website because
nobody else has done that yet and we
think it can be fresh but anyways I
digress I'm going with all this is that
the site is up everything but that whole
pledge system or the point system is in
there if you're listening to this
podcast right now and you haven't
checked it out please go check out the
site you subscribed thank you so much we
really appreciate it if you have not
subscribed and you don't want to
subscribe I would love if you could
leave a comment you know I may be on the
YouTube version of this podcast just
tell us like what would you what would
you look for that would make you want to
sign up for a site like this what would
it be what would what would you want to
see in something like this what would be
features that you would need to see and
there's also you can there's also an app
that you can get on your phone iOS or
Android as well if you want to watch
corridor videos there so yeah you know
we want to have the site launch we want
to be a want to be a platform that frees
us up from YouTube a little bit
we love YouTube it's great but you never
know when ads are going to just stop for
some reason it's it's not like we have
now an entire collection of families at
this point living off this YouTube
channel and we have no control over
YouTube so it's a little scary but we
love making videos I know there's a lot
of people out there who love watching
those videos and just want to rather we
want a direct way to connect with those
people you for example you who is
listening this podcast
right now so yeah not only that but also
if you think about the extreme disparity
and value when it comes to what a
low-cost subscription cannot allow to be
made versus what watching videos on
YouTube can allow can be allowed to be
made it's the equivalent if somebody
even just on patreon if somebody gives
us one patreon buck that is like going
out and sitting in front of your
computer and watching over a thousand
corridor videos yeah in terms of the
value that we get the value yeah so what
does that allow us to do right now all
the sudden what you can afford per
minute is totally different and now yes
there's less people I don't expect 10
million people to subscribe to a website
like obviously that would be phenomenal
[Laughter]
anyway you know like just that cost is
so dis is so there's such a difference
there and all of a sudden it's like oh
now we can create things that the core
audience has been asking for for years
like more DND content we can pair it
with live-action stuff we could do a
tutorial series that people keep asking
us for like hey why don't you guys do
because there is a there is a section of
the people that watch our videos who are
like hey you know be great is if you
guys actually did true tutorials on how
you now obviously there's a ton of
resources for that but one thing that
now the sudden becomes affordable that
people who might want to subscribe to
the website can afford and that we can
afford to make is that and 399 a month
for tutorial series is a lot cheaper
than than most you know so there's a
value that's given on that outside it
just it introduces this whole different
scale of flexibility that literally just
doesn't exist on YouTube because the
whole game on YouTube is like well how
does it fit within like this these
parameters it's got a it's got an appeal
to a general audience it's got to be
relatable to something in the cultural
zeitgeist
it's got to be ah you know easily easy
to produce at this amount and then we
have to be able to release it around
this amount of frequency and and
obviously those are those are guidelines
there's no hard and fast rules but man
you know like that only allows you to
make X Y & Z it's like yeah what do you
do I mean listen we're an hour into this
friend so anyway yeah I mean here's the
thing usually like the comparison I
think really drives at home you know if
a thousand people subscribe on the
website if thousand people so if a
thousand people are on the website they
subscribed that's equivalent to getting
a million views on a video on YouTube
right now right there's like a million
people watching VFX artists react like
it's the same thing it's just a thousand
people supporting us on the website so I
yeah you can literally make a video
series that a thousand people want to
watch and it is just as affordable for
our company as a video series that only
a million people watch on YouTube so
it's like that's just how I guess
devalued your view is on YouTube and
it's like how much the ad rates are but
it also goes to show that you can make
content that really serves a demographic
you know on a website so you know good
example this podcast gets a couple
thousand listens and I had you know I at
least we assume that those of you who
are listening to podcasts are you know
the tried and true diehard corridor fans
and people that like our content or
maybe you know I don't know maybe we
just you like listen to us talk and we
talk about interesting things who knows
but if you know this entire podcast I
guess listening group this audience like
if everybody here subscribed to the
website that would be the like the
equivalent of like all of our views and
all of our ad revenue by yeah and that's
only a couple thousand people you know
so anyways yeah if you want to go check
out the website I'd really appreciate it
she won't subscribe to the website I
really appreciate it obviously we all
would um I mean that'd be super cool but
most importantly I just want to hear
people's thoughts you know what would
you want to see in order to subscribe
would you be expecting from a site like
this or you just simply not known as
existed and you go and check it out okay
this is great this is exactly what I
want so yeah you know I just want to
hear your thoughts and do you think it's
worthwhile to subscribe go for it it's
still in beta right now you know
obviously we're still working on it so
you'd be in early but you know the funny
thing is if you literally buy like two
items in the store that 15% discount
will basically pay for your membership
for the year the website say more than
two merch items and then tie here
consider spread money already bought
three merch items you should be
subscribed
[Laughter]
yeah I already have it welcome it's a
very cute dog run in the books all right
cool good podcast everybody thank you
for listening if you happen to go check
out our site thank you so much I look
forward to your thoughts and impressions
in the comments of the YouTube video for
this podcast and if you haven't
subscribed even more thank you very much
yeah
it's a wild adventure we'll see where it
takes us yes sir all right all right so
long everybody see ya later